there is increasing backlash over the
way White House chief of staff John
Kelly handled the allegations of spousal
abuse against former staff secretary Rob
Porter
Kelly reportedly has said he is willing
to offer his resignation but a senior
White House official says Kelly's
resignation is unlikely even as
questions persist over Kelly's defense
supporter after the allegations of
spousal abuse became public
Errol Barnett is at the White House
Harold good morning good morning
yesterday president Trump spoke
glowingly of Rob Porter which is in
stark contrast to the terse words
offered by vice president Mike Pence but
you know what those mixed messages are
consistent with a White House that has
really sent muddled signals all week
after allegations of spousal abuse by
Porter first came to light it was very
sad when we heard about it and certainly
he's also very sad the president's
parting words for former staff secretary
Rob Porter made no mention of his
alleged victims he says he's innocent
and I think you have to remember that he
said very strongly yesterday that he's
innocent
it was a drastically different tones and
the one struck by the vice president in
interview while visiting the Winter
Olympic Games there's no tolerance in
this White House and no place in America
for domestic abuse pence did not respond
specifically to a question about chief
of staff John Kelly who was at the
center of the White House response to
the porter controversy the White House
has acknowledged that they could have
handled it better Porter told White
House Counsel dawn began more than a
year ago that his background check for a
security clearance might reveal
unflattering information but provided
few details
this past November Porter informed Kelly
that his ex-wives had made accusations
the Porter himself denied when the abuse
allegations became public Tuesday Kelly
came to Porter's defense
stating quote Rob Porter is a man of
true integrity and honor on Wednesday
photos surfaced of one of Porter's
ex-wives with a black eye press
secretary Sanders later announced Porter
would resign but not before this vote of
confidence Rob has been an effective in
his role as
secretary and the president chief of
staff have had full confidence and Trust
in his abilities and his performance
that night Kelley said he was shocked by
the new allegations but he also stood by
his previous comments of quote the Rob
Porter that I have come to know now CBS
News has learned that last night a
second White House aide resigned amid
spousal abuse allegations of his own
speech writer David Sorenson who denies
the allegations resigned on Friday a
White House official tells CBS News that
Sorensen's position did not require a
security clearance Anthony Errol Barnett
at the White House Thank You Erin